oh my gosh people are watching this
woman pop their pimples
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by wuga and i
will be putting my dietitian hat on to
look at the research on
diet and acne because let's be real
the stress of this pandemic and the 24
7 mask situation has probably been
pretty rough
on our skin so while you should always
speak to a dermatologist about your
unique skin care needs as i'm not a
doctor
or dermatologist today i'm going to be
providing some evidence-based
recommendations
and i'll be popping those pimple myths
on the best and worst
foods for your skin but first let's talk
about my sponsor
wuga everyone who knows me knows that i
love
a good murder mystery i have exhausted
my netflix options for all things true
crime so
as i've been waiting for something new
to watch i discovered
june's journey by wuka on my phone so
this is a really cool hidden object
mystery game
set in the 1920s available for free on
android and
apple mobile devices and on desktop
through amazon or facebook
i heard about it through a friend and
apparently it has a
really huge following with more than 30
million
people playing this thing worldwide i
honestly
was never really a gamer but i actually
really
like this game because it requires some
critical thinking skills
it has a solid storyline and beautiful
colorful graphics set in the glamorous
1920s
it's definitely been a really nice
distraction from the stress of covid
and also a more active alternative to
just watching tv
so if you need a little escape check out
the link in my description to download
june's journey
on one of your devices for free today
but before we dive in
you can pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to this channel and ring that little
bell so that you
never miss out on a video all right
let's begin
by breaking down the common causes of
acne
so acne forms when our pores become
clogged
by dead skin cells bacteria or excess
oil
often as a result of certain makeup
products genetics
medications sun exposure and of course
fluctuating hormones or you know when
you wear crappy cotton mask you bought
on etsy every single day for an entire
year
side note wear your damn mask moving on
mask knee aside hormones are definitely
a biggie for contributing to pimples
anywhere on your face or body
and it's definitely one factor that we
can't so easily manipulate
like we can our beauty regimen puberty
menstruation pregnancy menopause and
birth control
can all cause changes in our hormones so
for example
low levels of estrogen and higher levels
of testosterone
can increase oil production clog our
pores
and ultimately lead to zits this is why
a lot of us break out during
that time of the month and why 70 of
women with acne present with
high testosterone levels so obviously we
can't always do a whole lot about our
hormones but can we change the outcome
for our skin with what we eat well
not surprisingly research in this area
is
mixed and controversial since the look
and feel of our skin
like everything else about our body is
somewhat genetically determined
and highly individual so i absolutely
cannot make sweeping statements
suggesting
that you cut out specific foods or add
other ones
in as there's no such thing as a
universally understood anti-acne diet
that will make you look like you face
tuned but in real life
however the population research that we
do have
does draw some correlations and most of
them are rooted in the typical
western diet so what's going on with
this whole western diet
that makes us break out like a
pre-pubescent teen
well when people discuss the western
diet they're talking colloquial terms
about a diet high in refined sugars
and low in fiber-rich fruits and
vegetables we know that consuming an
excess of refined carbs without adequate
protein or fat
helps slow down its digestion and
absorption
can increase blood sugar levels and
subsequently
insulin insulin is related to a few
other hormone shifts
which also may play a role in acne
production so
one is an increase in testosterone which
we established
is a hormone that can increase oil
secretion this
could help explain why acne is often a
common side effect
of hormonal conditions that are
associated with excess testosterone
and insulin resistance like pcos the
other hormone linked to insulin levels
is called
insulin-like growth factor or igf-1
which also can potentially rev up the
oil factor as well
so what do we do about these greasy ass
hormones
well let's talk about some super general
diet recommendations that
may help some people manage their
breakouts and
notice that i say some people here
because again this is
not a one size fits all prescription
so it could take a little bit of
experimentation
number one swapping high for low
glycemic index carbs for those
unfamiliar with the glycemic index
it essentially categorizes carbohydrate
containing foods by
how fast they increase our blood sugar
levels
since the western diet tends to contain
greater amounts of
high gi or high glycemic index carbs
like white bread
potatoes pastries and sugar sweetened
drinks it's often suggested that we can
reduce the pimple producing
insulin related hormone cascade simply
by
reducing the glycemic load of our meals
so what does the research say well one
2017 study found that participants with
moderate to severe acne consumed more
refined carbs
compared to participants without acne
another large study
also found that frequent consumption of
high glycemic index foods was
associated with a 30 increase in acne
development
among teens research on adults in a more
recent 2020 study
found that those with acne were 54 more
likely to consume high sugar foods
compared to those with clear skin
finally to compare the effects of low gi
versus high gi foods on acne development
one review looked into the prevalence of
acne in indigenous groups
across different geographical locations
not surprisingly
the incidence of acne was lower in
populations
who consumed a low gi diet and as the
consumption of high gi foods increased
in these groups
so too did the prevalence of their zits
so does that mean that everybody should
be going on like a keto diet
hell no
[Music]
there's lots of carbohydrate containing
foods that are lower on the glycemic
index that you can include more often so
things like veggies
some fruits fiber rich whole grains and
legumes
and these foods may actually be
protective against a wide range of
health concerns
acne included so for example population
research suggests that
non-western populations consuming a low
glycemic index diet
rich in fruits veggies nuts meats and
whole grains have a comparatively lower
incidence of acne meanwhile in
randomized control trials
one study tested a low gi diet
intervention for
three months and found that it helped to
reduce testosterone
igf-1 levels and breakouts in young men
with acne
similarly another small trial found that
following a low gi diet for two and a
half months
also resulted in acne improvements so to
recap
when we eat an excess of high glycemic
index foods
our blood sugar levels go up which
stimulates the release of insulin
which increases the level of igf-1 and
testosterone
which revs up that oil production which
in turn can clog our pores
and cause acne now all of this
information is again
not to encourage you to cut out all the
high glycemic index foods in your diet
but it comes down to
trying to limit consuming a lot of naked
carbs
that is we want to consume the majority
of our carbs with a source of protein or
fat
to help slow down the blood sugar and
consequently
the insulin response so this could mean
pairing a high glycemic index food like
jasmine rice
with things like chickpeas cashews and
veggies for some protein
fiber and fat or you could smear that
white bread with some avocado
and top it off with some veggies and an
egg my longtime subbies are probably
saying in their head already
but it all comes down to the hunger
crushing
combination fiber protein and fat
that trio is not just for satiety
but it also may be for clear skin as
well
next let's talk about trialing dairy
free dairy is usually the first thing
that i hear people talking about
removing from their diet
when they're struggling with pesky
little breakouts and while it definitely
may help a lot of folks with skin
struggles
the research in this area is not
perfectly conclusive
one 2018 review found that people who
consume dairy milk
were 60 percent more likely to have acne
than those who don't and another large
2018 review
found that dairy consumption was
associated with the greater risk of acne
regardless of frequency or amount
consumed however another 2016 review
found only a weak association between
dairy and acne
so it's likely that there's something
there but it's not
100 clear and it may not ring true for
everyone while dairy is low on the
glycemic index
one theory for its role in breakouts is
that it may stimulate the production of
igf-1 in the blood
which again we establish may kind of
boost that oil production
we don't know for sure why this is but
there are some theories that it may be
related to
natural or artificial growth hormones
lactose sensitivity
or milk proteins like casein and whey
interestingly some research suggests
that higher fat dairy
may be easier on skin than things like
skim milk
likely because the fat may act as kind
of like a bit of a buffer
to some of those insulin and hormonal
cascade effects
but this is more of a theory than
anything and also not so well
substantiated in the literature
since other research has found a
positive association with the
consumption of
all milk including skim low fat and full
fat
regardless again obviously not everyone
breaks out after consuming dairy
and the evidence isn't so cut and dry i
know personally i have no issues with
any kind of dairy
but if you consume a lot of it and
you're struggling with frequent
breakouts
it might be worth a trial to go
dairy-free
thankfully there's a ton of great
dairy-free alternatives on the market
today
i just typically recommend looking for
one that's fortified with calcium and
vitamin d
and ideally one that has some protein
like pea milk
or soy next make fish friday a weekly
treat
i'm talking here about omega-3s and no
don't come at me kiss me outside how
about day you do not have to get them
from fish i was just saying that but we
do know
that omega-3s have a variety of
anti-inflammatory properties
and we also have evidence to suggest
that they may also play a role
at reducing breakouts by lowering igf-1
one large study found that teens who ate
more omega-3 rich fish
and seafood had less acne than their
fish
phobe friends well another study found
that people who took
omega-3 supplements were able to
simultaneously
improve both their acne and their mood
bonus
love me a good happy skin day
so in addition to fatty fish like salmon
trout sardines and mackerel you can also
find
omega-3s in walnuts flax omega-3
enriched eggs
and of course in fish oil supplements or
algae oil
next let's talk about eating the rainbow
and getting your antioxidant
fix so you've probably heard a million
boring ass psas a diet rich in fruits
and vegetables can help to reduce your
risk of chronic disease
true of course but let's be real
if you are a millennial or gen zed
you've probably kind of tuned those
recommendations out because
do you really give a [ __ ] about your
risk of heart attack or stroke no
probably not you want to look snatch in
your
i just woke up like this selfie well
good news lovers
because it turns out that foods that are
rich in antioxidants
are also good for your skin one 2008
population study found
that people who suffered from acne had
lower
levels of antioxidants like vitamins a
and e in their blood
while another study found that when acne
sufferers supplemented with antioxidants
like vitamin e and selenium their skin
condition
improved we definitely do need more
quality research when it comes to
actual supplementation and dosages
so i can't make any solid
recommendations on that but
considering that antioxidants are
naturally found in
so many nutritious foods most of which
are also
low glycemic index which we already
established are skin friendly
there really is no harm in including
them in your diet
you can find antioxidants in foods like
nuts
berries artichokes leafy greens red
cabbage
beans beets grapes green tea and orange
veggies
basically you don't need to do anything
that intentional or necessarily take any
expensive supplements
just eat a colorful very diet to get the
most beauty bang
for your buck and speaking of beauty
vitamins let's talk about everyone's
favorite sunshine vitamin vitamin d
vitamin d
is often cited as the cure-all for legit
everything from anxiety to covid to the
pimple on your chin from said anxiety
and
covet one correlational study found that
half of the people with acne
suffered from vitamin d deficiency and
then when they supplemented those
deficient with
about a thousand ius of vitamin d for
two months
their breakouts started to resolve these
findings were also echoed in a more
recent 2020 study
where the authors theorized that the
outcome was potentially linked
to vitamin d's natural anti-inflammatory
properties
now while food sources are limited to
things like fatty fish
mushrooms exposed to uv light and
fortified dairy
plant milk cereals and eggs we can
maximize our intake from
sun exposure and supplementation finally
let's talk about chocolate for a hot
minute because this is one
i know i'm going to get a lot of
questions about in the comment section
first of all there's actually not a
whole lot of good research to suggest
that there's
anything special or inherent about
chocolate
when it comes to acne risk one review
found a
very weak association between chocolate
and acne
but they also found a number of major
flaws
in research study designs most
significantly
a lot of the studies to date have not
controlled for the type of chocolate
used in their experiments
and that's kind of important since we
know that both sugar
and dairy products may play a role in
acne
and milk chocolate candy bars are
significantly higher
in both of these compared to let's say a
higher quality
dark chocolate bar so obviously if
you're like me
and you really only like the cheap mars
bars or the reese's peanut butter cups
and you find that sugar and dairy
products causes you to break out
yeah you might want to watch your intake
but if you're just looking to throw
a little cocoa powder into your smoothie
or enjoy a
square of 85 dark chocolate you might be
in the clear
so in conclusion you all need to know
that there is no one-size-fits-all model
when it comes to the anti-acne diet
so do not use this list as like a bible
of what you need to
include or cut out of your diet the
research in this area
is pretty spotty and not cut and dry the
same way that some people like
may get a tummy ache or fatigue from
gluten and others may not
some people may get pimples from cheese
and
others may not some of us are just
blessed with clear skin
and others are waking up covered in
spots on the regular
the bottom line is always speak to a
certified dermatologist to find the best
solution for you
which may or may not include making
changes to what you eat
but on that note that is all for you
guys today thank you again to wuga for
sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below
on what you'd like to see me cover next
subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye